[Musique]
eh bien, ça peut attraper, ils disent que nous
n'avons certainement pas besoin d'acheter des terres ou
même de louer des terres dans n'importe quel pays, nous avons
assez de terres ici et si nous avons besoin d'
augmenter la quantité de terres, nous avons eu
assez de lagons, euh assez  euh, dans notre région
au sein de nos
pays [Musique] [
Musique],
nous obtenons beaucoup de sédiments, bien sûr,
les sédiments accumulent tous les
récifs et bien sûr, cela suffira également
pour que les récifs détruisent le récif euh, nous
payons un prix énorme pour  euh, euh, les projets
vont
[Musique]
de
jour en jour, ils sont endommagés et le
blanchissement des coraux se produit très
souvent maintenant, c'est euh comme si je ne connaissais pas la
raison de ces choses mais je pense qu'à
mon avis, nous devrions tous être conscients de
la protection  nos récifs et l'
océan [Musique]
[Musique]
bonjour
toi